[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're back with DIY with Laura
and mac and she's showing us how to make
our own inexpensive and be inspired
console table all right so now as one
last step we're gonna yes literally
while you do that you go ahead you get
the caulk or the glue on there this is
industrial strength glue but while you
guys are looking at while she's doing
that I want you to see this this is the
finished product this is what it looks
like when it's all said and done we
sanded the edges after we use that uh
joint compound and this is the real
trick Louise at this point you can paint
this any color so that it customizes to
your Decor so you can do black you could
do white you know these neutral shapes
are really excuse me the neutral colors
is really a part of the japani design
it's very minimalism lots of neutrals
and bright neutrals do you see the
expression on my face yes girl you are
into this but it's like this is what
happens when I DIY or cook I look
incredibly uptight yes yes all right you
gotta get into it you got to be you got
to be committed I'm not like
I know I I do a lot of DIY videos and I
always look at my own footage and I'm
like why was I making that face
how is that yes that is it girl yes
okay A little top of wood how beautiful
is that all right
we did it
[Applause]
thank you Louise would something like
this suit your needs absolutely it looks
amazing it looks very easy to do so
can't wait well it's all yours if you
want it and if not we'll get you a gift
card for something in the Japan D style
that's underneath thank you
if you guys start decorating journey I
love that you do oh yeah you can have
this one and Louise can have that one oh
by the way that there's two of them
thank you so much thank you please come
back oh yes teach us we're going to get
you DIY stuff I want you to I want you
to get in here and do your do more of
these for your own self bring it on
[Music]
foreign